hey it's evan and today i got a question
from one of my youtube followers greg
who wrote in asking about evernote
saying i'm learning to use evernote
along with my android phone is there a
way to reduce the picture size when
using a phone as a scanner
seems the photos are large and choke
space quickly thanks for your videos
so greg yes there's actually a really
easy way to do this so let me
switch to my evernote here so i can show
you
so if i'm going to use my camera i'm
just going to click on the camera button
here
and then the trick is on the side here
where you have your options
click on that and then i guess it's not
that intuitive when you click
there's this button here where you see
two arrows pointing to the opposite edge
of the screen
click on that one and that lets you pick
the picture size
so i have an option eight five three two
megapixels one or vga
i have it set on the highest just
because when i'm scanning something in i
want the highest resolution possible
but if you're going to go lower just
pick whatever makes sense for you
so if i'm with the two then that's set
go back and start
snapping away with your camera it's as
easy as that
you